I would be flat out I would be
flat out lying if I said I was
disappointed if I said I
wasn't disappointed of course
it's a bit disappointed
it's just disappointing most
people here just to say the West
will be disappointed
and I'm being kind when I say
they're not as excited as I was
this morning but McAuliffe made
several mistakes unfortunately
there's many things that make
all that probably could
and should have done better like
allowing Duncan to beat him
to the punch on certain issues
like taxes and he allowed
himself rightly or wrongly to be
defined as a parents that debate
the education Yeah,
I think the grassroots support
wasn't there the grassroots
campaigning wasn't there like
it's been with many other
campaigns some of the ineptitude
of the Biden administration
and on the have done the Joel
and the Delta variants as well
as some of the stalemate
in Congress is all affecting
things locally because Biden was
then was not able to hasn't been
and and Congress have not been
able to get to the tubules
passed that has dragged his
approval rating down as well
as national Democrats no getting
around that.
But one thing is is I don't feel
that Republicans have to tell
the truth you can't lower taxes
and then increase education
funding funding I don't suppose
you have young kids playing this
game on the one hand appealing
to the Trump base with the all
this dog whistles
and at the same time you sort
of staying appealing
to the moderates with all his
push for education and economy
you know a good campaign I think
unfortunately.